시간이 지나서 현재이 청담동 건물의
시세는 주변에 뭐 2억에 매각이
되거든요 대지 평당 그렇게 감안했을
때 대지 면적으로 단순 계산해도 최소
400억 이상 될 것으로 좀 예상이
[음악]
됩니다네 안녕하세요 빌사남 있니다
제가 이번 시간에는 5년 전에 비슷한
금액으로 투자한 건물이 현재 투자
결과가 어떻게 됐는지 제가 사례를
준비했습니다 2018년도 에 이제
투자한 건물인데 신촌역 바로 앞에
있던 건물을 매입을 했습니다 그래서
여기가 유동 인구가 좀 굉장히 많고
그리고 지금 보시는 거와 같이 임차인
구성이라는 딱 봐도 수익률이 굉장히
좀 높게 나오는 그런 건물처럼 좀
보이는데이 건물이 2018년도에
148억 5천만 원에 매입을 했습니다
그래서 대지가 52평 정도 되고
연면적이 한 330평 정도 됩니다
대지 평당가로 봤을 때 약 한 2억
8천만 원 정도의 어 매입을 했는데이
건물과 비교해서 비슷한 시기에
145억 청남동 명품거리에 있는
건물을 매입을 했습니다 그래서요
건물인데 대지가 한 216평 정도
되고 연면적이 무려 743명 있니다
그래서이 건물을 145억 매입을
했어요 그래서 앞서 보셨던 건
148억 5천 그리고이 건물은
145억 매입을 했습니다 그 대지
평당가로 봤을 때는 한 6,700만
원 정도에 매입을 했고요 그래서 아마
인대 수익은 뭐 매입 당시에는 저기
신촌역에 있던게 뭐 인대 수익은 더
많이 나올 것으로 좀 예상이 되는데
대지 면적이 지금요 청담동 건물
대비해서이 청담동 건물은 한 네배
정도 더 크고 옆 면적은 두 배 정도
더 큽니다 시간이 지나서 현재이
청담동 건물의 시세는 주변에 뭐
2억에 매각이 되거든요 대지 평강
그렇게 감안했을 때 대지 면적으로
단순 계산해도 최소 400억 이상 될
것으로 좀 예상이 돼 입니다 이거와
비교해서 신촌역 건물은 이거보다 높진
않겠죠 아마 차액이 뭐 그렇게 좀
드라마틱하게 높을 것 같지 않습니다
그리고 또 세 번째 사례는 관철동
있던 건물이에요 그래서 이것도
2018년도에 매입을 한 건물인데
여기 종강력 먹자 상권에 있는 그런
건물이었습니다 그래서 지금이 건물인데
대지가 24평이에요 굉장히 작죠
그리고 연면적이 141편 있니다 같은
시기에 81억 원에 매입을 했습니다
그리고 이제 대지 평단 가로 봤을 때
한 3억 3천만 원 정도 그 정도에
이제 매입을 한 것으로 보여지고
임차인 구성도 좋고 임대 수익도 되게
좀 좋은 건물이었습니다 그리고 비슷한
시기에 강남구청역 인근의 역세권에
위치한 건물이었어요요 건물을 84억
5천에 매입했어요 그래서 아까 관철
동계 81억 그리고 요게 84억
5천에 매입을 했습니다 그래이 건물
같은 경우에는 대지가 112평이고
연면적이 345평 있니다 철동 건물과
대비했을 때 대지 면적은 약 한 다섯
배가 더 크고 연면적은 한 2.5배
정도 더 컸습니다 그리고 대지
평당가로 봤을 때는 한 7,500만
원 정도 매입한 것으로 좀 보여지고
그리고 여기 지역이 또 여기도
청담동이 그래서 지금이 건물의 현재
시세는 한 200억 이상 될 것으로
예상이 됩니다 그래서 뭐 관철동
건물은 여러분들이 한번 시세는 좀
예상해 보시면 좋을 거 같고 그래서
지금이 사례처럼 여러분들한테 말씀드
고싶은 한 세 가지 부분이 있어요
우선 첫 번째로 임대 수익률이 높은
건물 그리고 임차인 구성이 좋은
건물을 좀 비싸게 투자하지 않는게
중요한 거 같습니다 매입부터 좀
비싸게 매입했기 때문에 그 시세
오르는 폭이 좀 한정적일 수가 있고
그리고 만약에 상권이 죽게 되면은 그
하락 폭이 굉장히 좀 클 수 있습니다
그 부분을 좀 감안하시면 좋을 것
같고 그리고 두 번째로 면적의 중요성
면적이 아까 보셨겠지만 창천동 은 한
330평 근데 청담 동거는 한 740
정도 됐어요 그래서 한 두 배 정도
더 컸고 그리고 관철 동거 연면적은
141편 강남구청역 인근에 있는이
건물은 한 345평 정도 됐습니다 한
2.5배 정도 더 컸어요 이것처럼
물론 상권이 좋아져서 임대료가 더
오를 수도 있지만 그 면적에서
임대료를 낼 수 있는 그런 한계치가
있거든요 관철동 건물 같은 경우에는
대지 면적이 24평이고 물론 예전에
지어서 건폐율을 거의 100% 받긴
했지만 그래 봤자 이제 한 계층 바닥
면적이 한 20평 초반 정도 되거든요
들어올 수 있는 인차 업종이 좀
제한이 있을 수도 있고 임대료를 낼
수 있는 그런 한계치가 있어요
여러분들이 면적을 좀 중요시 봐야
됩니다 내가 건물 투자할 때 면적을
어느 정도 쓸 수 있고이 정도
면적에서 임대료를 최대 어느 정도
받을 수 있는지요 부분을 체크하시면
좋을 거 같고 그리고 마지막으로
환금성이 높은데 투자를 해야 됩니다
청담동 거 건물 같은 경우에는 주변에
계속 좀 비싸게 매각이 되고
있거든요이 지역 전체적으로 좀 가격이
계속 오르고 있습니다 그리고 매각도
굉장히 좀 잘되고 있고 여러분들이
빌딩 투자할 때 환금성이 높은 데를
투자하셔야 돼요 여러분들이 이렇게
돈이 모이는 곳에 투자를 하셔야지
안정적으로 어 시세 차익을 좀 볼 수
있다라고 저는 생각을 합니다 제가 뭐
세 가지 좀 포인트를 말씀드렸는데이
부분을 좀 기억하셨다가 여러분들이 딩
투자하는데 있어서 좀 도움이 되셨으면
좋겠습니다 제 영상이 마음에 드셨다면
구독과 좋아요 눌러 주시고 이제 다음
시간에 뵙도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다